we'll we'll leave with this first story
because this is like the
this is the craziest thing let me check
this out from the daily mail they say
debate commission promises rule change
to make next showdown orderly
after dumpster fire clash which biden
admits was a national embarrassment but
unrepentant trump says it was fun i
think that's all you need to know
right there but there's a few more
bullet points they say the commission on
presidential debates has vowed to change
the format
of the next candidate clash last night's
debate made clear that additional
structure should be added
to ensure a more orderly discussion on
the issues the commission said
the verdict came down after changes
called for
in uh called for in wake of catec night
joe biden called it a national
embarrassment
the morning after the debate trump
called the event fun claiming he
actually was debating biden and fox news
moderator
and fox news moderator chris wallace two
on one was not surprising but fun trump
tweeted
radical left is dumping sleepy joe zero
democrat enthusiasm weak leadership
a general consensus was reached the
debate was a dumpster fire
most claim neither candidate came out on
the uh the other side looking good
i'll tell you this the point i was
making like when we opened the show for
those that may have missed the context
there
donald trump's having a good time just
talking over everyone and dominating
everything
he's loving it that's his environment
joe biden needs help
like how is he how is he going to
negotiate anything for us or
i don't know what he's a terrible
negotiator he's got a low diplomacy
skill
is that where's that come from biden
yeah and just listening to him he's he's
he's always he's he's dry yeah and he's
and he's just
you know a lot of people were saying i
don't know if you guys saw that point
where
biden said would you shut up man you
know that point yeah
a lot of people like cheering for that
but i'm like that wasn't a
like you know donald trump when he's
doing the wwe style thing and he's like
you know hoot at the crowd and flexing
he's high energy when he's shutting
people down excuse me excuse me no
no joe biden goes would you shut up man
that was defeated yeah one thing was for
sure that trump energy he overwhelmed
the stage the television the broadcast
america his energy
was 10x everybody last night and that's
been something that he's been pushing
all along right high energy aggressive
in your face
creating drama making things interesting
you know that's right that's why it's
sleepy joe
and trump is the man at this point yeah
trump uh
he's spry he's dude has he not okay so
you remember when obama went and came
into office
no grace looking young eight years later
he looks like
like an old man he looks like like some
energy vampire
latched onto him and drained him he's
like ah right but has trump degraded in
any way physically over four years in
fact it seems to me like he's getting
bigger picking up he's gotten bigger and
like
his hair is growing larger oh no oh yeah
no i think i think trump's calmed down
in a certain respect
but he's actually like last night was
probably the most riled up
i've seen him like he was just going off
yeah he was debating chris wallace and
joe biden at the same time
yeah and it was clearly a strategy right
like they did they didn't ease into that
like trump
didn't ease into his aggression did you
notice he didn't
open with the typical opening usually
they ask you a question
and then you say thank you everybody for
having me here
thanks to everybody at the university
thanks to the ushers and my wife and
blah blah
and then they take like 90 seconds
saying thank you to everybody and then
they get into the question
trump just started off attacking just
came out swinging did you even say thank
you joe biden tried he did
he was like i always want to thank you
it was funny when he walked down he
looked at trump and he's like
you know whatever like uh i'm joe biden
whatever i don't know
yeah joe biden it seems like he didn't
know if he was going to play it wwe
style
like you know like smack talking in the
ring or if he was going to try and have
a
traditional establishment debate but
then
joe biden just jumped in into the muck
with with trump and you know the
the main issue i see is you can't win
that fight definitely not
what's the phrase like don't fight with
the pigs they'll drag you into the mud
yeah you lie with dogs you get fleas so
so so donald trump we
that's like you know man they don't have
to deal with this guy
donald trump comes out he's in the wwe
hall of fame isn't he i'm pretty sure
he's been a big part of it he's made
guest appearances they love him and
they love him in the mma world too so he
knows about this showmanship
yup that well i mean for for like uh
wrestling entertainment
it really is about putting on that big
spectacle and catching the attention of
the crowd
i think we have all we have all the
polls saying that joe biden won
you know like nine nine out of ten or
whatever polls some ridiculous number
there's that one telemundo poll saying
uh spanish speakers
think trump won 66 to 33. that's crazy
and there were a few other polls like
c-span did a non-scientific twitter poll
and people are
popping that up i think trump won um and
i know it's probably
i'll tell you this it's it's it's
probably i don't know if cliche is the
right word oh of course tim's gonna say
trump won because you know they're gonna
be like
the the the maggots will just say trump
won no matter what it's like
dude i got a lot to say about how trump
screwed up in a lot of ways
but that's why i opened with imagine joe
biden trying to have a conversation with
vladimir putin
no one's going to be there to hold him
up so we can complain
that we didn't get any substance i think
that's partially true i think donald
trump
did have a bunch of really important
issues he talked about when he went into
mail-in voting joe biden just sat there
for like two minutes just not saying a
word and then he goes
there's no evidence for that it's like
that's not a response joe
that's not you can't just be like that's
not true you're dumb you know
i felt like i felt like trump had a
command of the facts like he had
in the past you know before he was just
coming out like four years ago you know
he wasn't president he didn't have
programs he didn't have the experience
but now it's like he knows everything
that's going on yeah and
and compared to joe biden who even my my
son
pointed out that joe biden would say
well you know it was 20 million i mean
uh 20 000 i mean 20.
every statistic that he tried to cite so
if biden wanted to do a clinical
debate about policy issues it seemed to
me that biden did not have
the facts the knowledge or even maybe
the preparation or the temperament or
the energy or something
but when he tried to do that it wasn't
working for him at all let me all right
so
let me ask you something so uh jack's
been on the show before i'm sure you
guys
may have seen i think now it's like your
third third time and uh you wrote you
literally wrote the book on it
democratic deplorable
has has anyone else done what you've
done like traveling around asking people
about all this stuff
uh there was a woman that was doing some
stuff like that uh back a few years ago
and her book came out and it just came
and went
and my book continues to sell more and
more every month as people are waking up
the democrats are waking up to what's
going on and they're embracing donald
trump and they've had four years to have
to figure out like all those things that
that drove people away into
2016 10 times worse today i had a
conversation today that i think
you like i'm surprised some of the
people i know may be finally breaking
off of the biden
try to train but i bring i bring this up
someone ask you on a scale of 1 to 10
in 2016 what level was your enthusiasm
for donald trump like just before
election
uh enthusiasm like did i want him to win
was i supporting him that was a ten
a ten yeah i was all in i was all in
trump did i think he was gonna win
no and even in my book i sat i reflected
about election night
sitting down with my girlfriend red hen
on twitter and just being like
it's been a fun ride babe but i just
don't think i just don't think it's
gonna happen going back to hillary yep
and then when wisconsin came in and then
i mean man then then we just went
bonkers man that was such a fun night
yeah it was like it was like christmas
and new year's at the same time and like
yeah
all the holidays holidays rolled into
one yeah and i i'm not saying that as
someone who voted for trump i'm saying
it as somebody who was watching just
like
all these establishment elitist pricks
who are so smug and sure of themselves
it's like dude i didn't vote for trump
man
i didn't vote for hillary i'm just
sitting back minding my own business
trying to have a slice of pizza and a
beer
and you guys wouldn't stop gloating and
snooting about sniffing your own farts
to watch them fall down from the ivory
tower was just hilarious yeah
comeuppance right indeed
so now we'll see what happens and i
gotta say i'm not uh
i'm not con i'm not convinced at this
point with the amount of smears and the
chaos that's been dropping about trump
that he's on track for a victory but but
the reason i ask this question is
if you were at a a 10 out of 10 in in
2016
as of right now with everything that's
happened where are you at for trump well
i'm at 10 out of 10
times 10 at this point in terms of
support yeah right like i see him as the
only way out of this
existential crisis that we're in
critical race theory the woke walkers
the whole thing
right that's awesome yeah that's a good
one
usually it's a good reaction
and so you know my support for him is is
as high as it could be
at this point now i go back and forth on
whether or not i think he's actually
going to win
i i feel like it's been building
momentum i really do i don't think the
debate helped
sort of grow more enthusiasm you know or
optimism on my part
but i i have been feeling really good
and i don't really i look at the polls i
disregard them
and it's just sort of a vibe but you
know who knows at this point
i would say that i probably went down a
little bit
in terms of after the debate yeah
definitely yeah even though he won
even though he won the it's not it's not
to a point where i'm like oh geez i
better not vote or i better vote for
biden oh i'm definitely gonna vote i'm
definitely gonna vote for trump
but i was just like there were you would
think that
when he was asked again about disavowing
white supremacy
and i understand he's done it a billion
times but that was his moment
to calmly and rationally just be like
yes
next question and then he could have
pointed to joe biden and said now will
you disavow antifa in the far left
and joe wouldn't have done it and that
would have been a grand slam for trump
and he missed the queue yeah the
question he was given though like i
think tripped him up
right do you disavow white supremacy and
militias exactly right so like there's a
lot of people in militias there's a lot
of people who aren't white supremacists
who are malicious and there's a lot of
people like that that support trump
i can see in his brain maybe where he
didn't want to just come out and say yes
to that question but he should have
like he does all the time well no i
answer whatever question he wants
and he had a moment there and he he did
miss it
so i so the the way i phrased it earlier
was like i was probably at a six out of
ten and i'm like a 5.7
like it went down a little bit because
i'm just like but biden can't win when
he said the
proud boys should stand back and stand
by i think that was his ego
that he didn't want to capitulate to the
to the moderator and just say stand down
because they're like say stand down say
stand down and no just wouldn't do it
because his ego i think he misspoke
yeah maybe no i really do i think he
like this listen this is not a defense
of trump
if trump just stopped for two seconds
and you know so chris wallace is like
will you disavow white supremacists
and the right-wing sure it's like he
jumped in before chris wallace
if trump just stopped for a second let
chris wallace say the question
then trump could have calmly replied
instead it was just people were yelling
and it was kiss
and it's and it's it's partly because
actually i want to stop and preface this
because you pointed out biden's the one
who broke the decor first two minutes
three minutes in violated the rules and
so then it just
goes chris wallace should have said stop
you do not interrupt
you do that again you're losing your
time and he said nothing
and but so i think trump was like oh
rules are off yeah
well well trump was waiting for it too
so but but if trump just slowed down
and said it's really really simple if
you ask me
you know will you disavow white
supremacy and right-wing militias i
would say
i disavow all white supremacist
organizations in fact
donald trump announced that the klan are
going to be designated domestic
terrorists yeah
so he's like we we just announced we're
designating people domestic terrorists
is that not good enough i think i think
we've done pretty well there now as for
any right-wing militia that is looking
to start violence
don't do it these people need to stop
by all means you're free to speak your
mind and you're free to be in your
militia and you have all of your rights
but we need the violence to stop now
trump did say i want peace
i'm not trying to make it seem like i'm
you know i'm trying to say like trump is
a failure or anything like that like oh
how dary
i'm saying he missed a cue on that one
it was a great opportunity
yeah and you pointed this out earlier
when we were talking where like
chris chris walls asked that question of
him four years ago
yeah mike what do you point to that i
think yeah and well and and you were
like
you know he had the same chance then he
disavowed 100 right then he disavowed
you know the kkk disavowed you know duke
disavowed everybody
maybe he's just getting tired of it i'm
tired of it we're all tired of it
that's a stupid question and and his
first response was sure
and they're acting like he didn't say
that he gave an affirmative but weak
response
and the media all of a sudden every
story like oh no trump won't disavow and
then this morning that's when he's like
oh yeah yeah
they should stand down with law
enforcement let's think about this the
media is going to say whatever they're
going to say no matter what trump says
right so does it make sense for him to
just sort of answer the question however
he wants
rather than you know sort of give in to
the demand of the
of the moderator and that's that's a
good point and and you know what
a lot of people have been saying like
chris wallace couldn't handle it we need
joe rogan
and joe rogan said no and he was like
get the mma broadcaster guy and then he
was like no way nobody wants to touch it
because it was just like a
hot pile of you know trash but uh i'd
i'd love to i'd love to moderate you
know why because i just wouldn't do it
right
i'd be like 15 minutes on the clock the
subject is covid
have that boys i'll be in the other room
50 minutes i'll come back in and i'll
hit the buzzer again and we'll switch
topics you know what's gonna be funny is
when if they do try
doing the the the mic cutting yeah
they're gonna cut as much they're gonna
cut the mic but trump's gonna be
so loud that like you're gonna hear him
come through on the other yeah
what they're going to need to do is put
them in separate locations with somebody
on a video mixer and just be able to cut
the feed entirely right i
i think this is insane that anyone would
accept joe biden requiring a handicap
to have a a debate on issues listen
it's it's it's sales 101 man if people
don't know about your product they can't
buy it
if donald trump is the one who's saying
words
we can look at all the debate polls
where they're like well actually joe
biden was the one who really came out
with substance yeah
no that doesn't that's how it works i
used to work for nonprofits i used to do
fundraising and i'll tell you this
you know what got people to give me
their money it wasn't me saying let me
cite this statistic now in 2017 we
actually
cut down 4.3 tons of carbonation no it
was me
triggering their emotions ah yes that's
it
and one of the most important things in
sales is always having a response to
soothe their worries
so when someone says to me i'm scared
this is one of the things they teach you
when you're doing street canvassing for
these non-profits you know those people
who are like howdy would you like to
talk about the environment
no oh but man me and my buddies were
like nation's best
we could snap our fingers and and have
somebody in front of us signing up
hanging over their credit card
what so here's what here's a like big
mistakes
people make if someone asks you a
question say like i'm nervous about
voting for donald trump
do not give them 800 reasons you give
them one simple one
this now when they say yeah but this
then this
and you you whenever they give you a
response showing you they're scared
you give them an answer if you can
answer every question
they'll eventually cave and say i'm not
worried i have nothing else to ask you
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you